[Music]
Decker agent Jackson he'll be working
with him on this mission
he's nice Jackson let's keep one thing
straight
I don't like orders and I don't play by
the rules but rusty heard of me actually
know what happened
[Music]
we don't have much time the arachnid
agents have taken over the consult we
need to get you in and resolve this from
the inside we've taken the latest sitrep
of the hostiles position and we've
reconstructed a holographic blueprint of
the consulate save the mouth squirt for
the newer occurs general not gonna be
impressed by any finish it's just a 3d
representation pretty standard these
days agent Jackson you will enter
through this AC duct on the south side
of the building
yes sir Decker you will be dropped on
top and then you will gain access
through this elevator shaft we want you
to go down to the fourth floor mate
Decker you okay yeah heard everything
you said elevator shaft it's bright yeah
it's bright the terrorists are located
on the third and fifth floor of the
building each floor has six groups of
six men what we're gonna want you to do
is stop in the middle at the 4th and pry
open the elevator door and go I just
want you to move through that elevator
door and then go down
elevated or go down to the third floor
[Music]
okay maybe this isn't gonna work out why
it was matter general everybody's
putting their hand in the laser it's not
a laser it's a hologram tomato tomato
look ma sweat all the babysitting and
hand-holding Papa's a big boy let's zoom
into the interior yeah
[Music]
let's cut to the chase why am I here
your primary target is your old rival
from the cold war nikoli androkovich
Patrick Kovich has been leading a good
job Decker Jackson was an undercover
agent for arachnid how in the world did
you know ain't my first rodeo
[Applause]
in my day we made coffee hard
you